Chinese market has long been a gold mine
for many German companies with high-end
car makers like Audi and Mercedes making
an ever larger share of their profits
here but the BDI Federation for German
industry claims the Chinese market is
far from a level playing field the
business lobby accuses Beijing of using
a combination of protectionism price
dumping and state subsidies to bolster
China's economy and cement the central
government's control divide the the
development of a free market isn't on
Beijing's agenda the central government
is trying to expand the Communist Party
control of the economy and civil society
and that's become more apparent in the
last three years there is also growing
concern that China's shopping tour of
buying controlling shares of German
high-tech companies like robotics
manufacturer cuca could soon lead to a
strategic disadvantage for Europe in the
report the BDI is calling on Berlin to
take action to make the economies of
Germany and Europe more resilient among
the demands increased scrutiny of
China's state support for firms that
compete with European companies and more
oversight of Chinese acquisitions the
BDI also says Western countries must do
more to defend their lead in technology
of course we need to do our own homework
first and increase our own
competitiveness by investing more in
infrastructure and education including
research by expanding the use research
budget of the birth often for jean paul
station the BDI also believes you
members must close ranks to ensure China
does not eventually gain a competitive
edge in technology and let's go back to
our frankfurt corresponds it a net 5
spot annette we've seen how the US has
chosen to handle this issue of chinese
competitiveness is the EU really in a
place to get tough on China it could
actually be a good timing because China
is has a lot of problems currently with
its economy and they might actually be
willing to compromise more than ever
before what they're trying currently is
to devaluate their currency and to sell
their products even cheaper to the
international market and that is what
everybody is saying now
wait on a minute this can't be like
sustainable we're seeing that but the
solar in a solar sector for example
China was offering their products at
really low prices which then led to the
destruction the demise of the solar
industry in a way here in Germany and at
the same time there's also a widening
concern that china is just buying into
technology in the West with sort of
investors which have stayed backing so
what currently politicians are
discussing and what they are arguing is
that there needs to be a level playing
field it can't be that the Chinese state
is supporting investors and yet kind of
makes it possible to buy for them so
perhaps a window now as the Chinese
economy weakens a net vise Bock they're
forced in Frankfurt Thank You Annette
you